foreign
[Music]
Jeffersonville moving on up what's up
Patrick
good morning Dr John how are you
excellent what's up
um I came to a bit of a
estimation that I'm starting to lose my
five-year-old son a little bit and I'm
trying to figure out how I can do a
course correction before it gets too
late and you know it's just completely
broken between us
what's what is helping you arrive at
that conclusion
just uh a couple weeks ago I was in you
know kind of an office again on again
Affair and during that time
I would have communication with the
affair partner
you know I would throw everything to the
wind I would even kind of push him back
and I are you married yes
so you had a three-year affair
how long have you been married
uh for gonna be seven years okay so for
three of the seven years you were
cheating on your wife
yeah okay and three of his five years
this little boy's five years
yeah and my guess is before you start
having an affair your marriage kind of
sucked then too right
yeah I mean we wasn't in the best of
places
so your marriage kind of sucked too
right
yeah yeah okay so the kid was born into
a house of Chaos
and or a house of tension let me put
that way
and then you did something to relieve
your attention you didn't like who you
were becoming in this relationship and
you found somebody else for three years
did your wife know about this affair
uh not in the beginning but uh when it
first started it took a couple of months
before it was exposed to her
and then she was just dope with it
happening for two more years
uh no that's that's another issue that
we've we're we've been having and he's
been wrapped up in what's that issue
uh me not me not being faithful and not
coming to her with the issues that I was
having and instead seeking out this
other person
hmm
okay let me let me back that thing up
and okay let me try to get this all the
way in
so you get married a couple years in you
meet somebody else or you already knew
somebody else
you have an affair for a few is that
right go ahead yeah you have an affair
for a few months
your wife finds out
she either busts you or you told her
and then you get it all out she decides
to stay with you
and then you decide to keep having this
affair in secret for two and a half more
years
and she would find out every once in a
while or something like that
yeah there would be you know just flip
UPS on my parts where I'd get careless
and she would see the message on my
phone or um bro what's the matter with
you dude what do you mean you got
characters
I was I'd say that's what I'm trying to
wear I've got a another
personal therapist that I speak with and
I'm trying to work that out to
um because I've you know to myself I've
been living a giant life for the last
three years and
you've been living a life for way longer
than three years
you didn't screw up or slip up
I mean I guess you did if you're like
talking to a group of dudes who cheat on
their wives you're like oh I screwed up
I got busted
man and she stuck with you through all
of this
yeah I mean she she's a sweetheart she
is no she's a doormat
she is not a sweetheart that's how I
treated her and she is a doormat who is
in desperate need of being able to look
in the mirror and say I'm worth way the
hell more than this
and here's the deal I get dude I get it
I get the screw up I get the weekend
like oh my gosh I get the you spend a
lot of time with somebody you work with
and they end up becoming your best
friend I get all of that
three just Thumb in your nose at your
wife's face for three years man that's
tough
just yeah guy to guy that's tough man
because that's just been that's just
pissing on your wife dude that's just
not cool
and it's been tearing at me for you know
that long and even knowing that I I knew
it was wrong and that I shouldn't be
doing it there was just that you know
that Euphoria the high of when
I would have that connection with the
other person and then you would come
down on the other side and she's like my
goodness this was not worth it we need
to stop
bro you're you're not there yet man
you're not there yet
so yes if your kid is anxious if your
kid is struggling with hyperactivity if
your kid is struggling with Focus one
thousand percent yes he's right where he
should be there's not a a one damn thing
wrong with him
because he is living in a house of lies
and he's living in a house of
disconnection and he's living in a with
a mom
who is desperately hanging on to
somebody who thinks about it as much of
her as he does
the dog crap he picks up in the backyard
and he's living with a dad who's a
habitual liar
and that little boy is anchored into
connection I mean to he's just anchored
into he's untethered he's a kite in the
Wind and there's no string
and I agree with that and I see that
from him because like you said whenever
you know we try to talk uh his mom and I
it's you know he starts acting crazy not
crazy as in like lunatic but jumping on
the couch with button in or trying to
instill our attention back to him
kind of like he's the mediator kind of
de-escalate the situation because he's
been the mediator trying to de-escalate
the situation for five freaking years
Fair
yeah yeah he's just doing his job that's
the job y'all gave him because no one
else is being an adult in that house
are you still have an affair now
no no I I came totally clean with her
the last week uh or second last week of
September
you know I laid everything that was
going on out there
and how long has it been since you've
been with this other person
uh
the first week of September was the last
time I seen
I think so for those of you we record
these several weeks ahead so it's been
about a month
right
yeah yeah
you're not done having an affair Yet
brother
because that high feeling is every bit
as
foreign
it's about you feeling alive dude and
you have a wife and a kid and it's easy
to get dead-eyed real fast in life to
get real boring real fast and you don't
like who you become when you're
dead-eyed and bored
and this other person makes you feel
alive because she doesn't have to live
with you and you don't have to live with
her and you can play Fantasy for two and
a half hours
and that's why I'm trying to get more
intentional with it in the beginning you
don't try to get intention with this you
never freaking talk to her again ever
ever you delete her from everything you
throw your phone in the trash in the
toilet
that's basically what I did I I'm off
social media my in the beginning I
wouldn't give my wife my phone she has
complete and total access to my phone I
have the accounts but she has the
passwords I don't log into the app
they're not on my phone for me to log
into them
and I'm I'm taking more of the steps
forward that I didn't take in the
beginning to where I was more bullish
and stubborn and
this is about you saying I'm giving up
my power because you've got power over
her
and it feels good to have power over
somebody finally in your life
and it's about you taking a knee so good
for you man you've done you've given up
your cell phone passcodes cool
I've talked to too many guys who cheated
on their wives
and when they're ready to stop cheating
there is a totally different way that
they come across as a totally different
ethos
I don't hear it on you it may be if you
and I were hanging out man I don't want
to I don't want to judge you just by the
tone of your voice man because I can't
even see you
um
but this isn't something you just kind
of figure out you just kind of working
on it it is scorched Earth man
this is falling down on your face in
front of your wife and saying I failed
you
oh and not only that I failed you I
broke your heart and then I took your
heart and I just
rubbed it in the dirt and stomped on it
because she were too much of a chump to
leave me
and here's the thing with here comes to
your son dude you can't say anything
your words simply do not matter to him
one thing will matter to him and that is
action
okay he is watching everything you do
and if you walk into that home and
you're an agent of Peace the house gets
more warm when you show up
and you walk right past him are his arms
are outstretched and you walk right past
him
and you go grab his mother gently by the
face and you look her in the eyes and
say I love you and every day of the rest
of my life is dedicated to meeting your
needs
I will find my aliveness
through reinvigorating our love
and then you hug her for 15 to 30
seconds every day before you even
acknowledge that kid
then over time 60 90 120 days a year
later
when he sees you all together his body
will begin to say that's right not
that's War which is what his body says
now
okay and then if you commit to never
taking your cell phone out of your car
when you get home
so that you are fully present and by the
way
if you're like me it's awkward I don't
know what to do man when I'm just
sitting there with two little kids and
my wife I don't know what to do my body
starts rattling a little bit
so I gotta have a set of practices
sometimes I have to change my
environment I got to go get on the floor
and play with my kids I got a wrestling
mat upstairs I go wrestle with my kids I
got two
do a puzzle that I've done a hundred
thousand times I gotta do it again
right
being a parent sometimes is super boring
and my life isn't just about me being
entertained
it's about being with not over with
and every day of your life you got to
wake up and address your wife in the in
public in your living room or in your
kitchen and say how can I best love you
today what does today look like for us
and she might say get out go to work and
you'll go great I'm gonna have a great
day at work
and she might say I just need you to sit
by me not say anything can we just have
coffee and you say no words and you'll
say yep absolutely
do you see what I'm getting at
yeah that's why I don't think you're
here I don't think you're there yet
because you're talking about
completely cashing in your entire Mo
which is I know something you don't know
I've got power over you and I can do
whatever the hell I want whenever I want
because you ain't going nowhere
and that's something that I've been
working with with my therapist and
something that I've I don't like about
myself and I don't I can't stand I mean
when I I hold on to that and it's I know
that you know these last three years
that she hasn't went anywhere so I've
been able to just you know do whatever I
want I had the keys to the car and I was
driving it
and I don't I don't want to live like
that I don't want to treat my wife that
way I don't want to raise my children in
that type of environment I want to be
the best need that I can be for them and
for her
so it's not total chaos and it's not
tension and stressful to where we're
bickering and we're arguing or just not
talking like we're roommates and
like we're still madly in love like we
were when we were teenagers
you're not hey you're not going to be
madly in love like you were when you
were teenagers
you're not
the sex in your marriage at year 10 will
be infinitely better than it was Year
One
and the sex in your marriage in your 15
and 20 will be infinitely better than it
was in Year One
what you don't have is perspective on
that yet
madly in love like ah I'm gonna blow off
class and I'm gonna skip school and I'm
gonna go put a bunch of crap on the
credit card to that goes away
and then you build something infinitely
more structurally sound
but if you keep chasing madly in love
dude your marriage is going to end up in
Ash and you're gonna burn those kids to
the ground
you have to chase something bigger than
that
something deeper than that
and that my friend is love
and I'll I'll I would be willing to bet
you don't even know what that looks like
you'd never see it your parents didn't
show you your old man didn't show you
and I I honor that dude it's a set of
skills that you don't I'm asking you to
mow a yard and you've never seen a
lawnmower you've never seen grass okay
that's your mission is to figure that
out
what love looks like
as the great poet Stephen Connell says
love is a promise that comes what comes
I will be right here
and you've got to learn that
and the all of your figuring out
language dude enough with that you do
need to figure out some skills no
question I'm glad you're working with a
counselor you do need to figure out at
some point where you learned this that
people are worth being treated that way
but all this I'm trying to learn it no
never raise your voice again in your
home
whenever you start to get into an
argument with your wife put both hands
up and stop it and say hey hey hey
I love you too much to continue in down
this road and we've been down this road
and we know where it leads so I'm not
gonna fight you let's Circle back in 30
minutes okay
whenever she says hey you make me feel
like you don't butt in with your yeah uh
you you say I'm so sorry
how can I help make this right
and you can say whatever you want to to
that little boy
if you want him back treat his mom right
you want him back
be present with him you want him back
tell the truth you want him back invite
him into a life of peace
not a life of War
voluntarily give your attention to him
don't make him work for it
hug him for 30 seconds every day of his
life and put your hands on his face kiss
him on the forehead if he'll aloud kiss
him on the face on the cheeks on the
neck tell him that you love him
with your actions
got a long way to go my brother
I'm optimistic for you man you got real
real real lucky with who you married
it's time for you to step up and do your
part